kanye west is moving on from kim
kardashian
and he's doing it with irena shay
literally
the news no one saw coming we were out
of our minds
to even think like something like this
could really happen a source tells et
that yay and irina have
casually been seeing each other and the
two have kept things on the dl for a
while as they're both
very private they're excited and the
pair were just spotted in france
together
yay and irina were in the french region
of provence and were seen smiling and
strolling around their luxury hotel
i'm very spontaneous yeezy was wearing
all black with a gold chain necklace
while irena sported a white crop top and
baggy black pants
the new pair were together for yay's
44th birthday
you know while kim and the whole fam
were on the gram wishing him the best on
his special day
i'm doing totally fine our source adds
the rapper and the model have a lot in
common
saying quote kanye loves having someone
in the fashion world as that's a big
part of his life
and irina enjoys connie's passion for it
kanye and irina have been friends for
more than a decade now
if you remember the 35 year old french
model previously appeared as an
angel in the 2010 music video for
kanye's hit power
she also walked in his 2012 yeezy
fashion show
and yay even name dropped her in his
2010 song
christian dior denim flow
both kanye and irina are coming off high
profile breakups
the 35 year old model dated actor
bradley cooper for four years
calling it quits in 2019. as for yay
he's in the middle of his divorce from
kim you just got to roll with it
in february the 40-year-old reality star
filed for divorce from the rapper after
six years of marriage i've seen him go
through
a lot so how does kim feel all about
this
well on tuesday a source told e.t that
kim is unbothered and not concerned with
her ex's dating life
she has quote more important things to
deal with and is really focused on her
children
at the end of the day life is about
being happy being
who you are but she's finding it
difficult to move on from kanye and that
their divorce is still pretty emotional
and not fully resolved
i honestly can't do this anymore during
part one of the series finale of keeping
up with the kardashians
kim broke down in tears over her
marriage troubles with kanye
i actually deserve someone that can go
support his every move
and go follow him all over the place and
move to wyoming i can't do that
he should have a wife that supports his
every move and
travels with him and does everything and
i can't i feel like a [ __ ] failure
that it's like a third
marriage yeah i feel like a loser
but i can't even think about that like i
want to be happy and even if kanye has
moved on
the source adds kim always has the
support of her family
i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
you